fall 1993 Executives from America's top
defense contractors were invited to the
Pentagon the Cold War was over and they
were anxious to hear about the future
the Secretary of Defense didn't waste
his words defense spending would be
reduced and fast and many of the
companies represented in the room
wouldn't survive and they didn't fast
forward to October 2020 deep in the
heart of the same building while the
rest of the world is reeling from the
covid-19 pandemic U.S military planners
were running a war game on paper the
enemy didn't have a name but everyone in
the room knew it was meant to be China
the US didn't just lose it had its clock
cleaned the vice chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff said that the enemy knew
exactly what we were going to do before
we did it and they took advantage the
war game proved that the U.S military
was struggling to cope with the new way
of war and it showed everyone that China
could actually win if you care about
things like democracy and Free Speech
this should scare you but the United
States has an ace of its slaves an
untapped source of talent that can help
its military reclaim its status as the
best in the world and in this video I'm
going to tell you about it to fully
understand this story we've got to go
back to the 1940s
during his presidency Franklin Delano
Roosevelt would often talk to the
American people via scripted Fireside
Chats these were significant events
families would huddle around the radio
to hear what the president had to say
Roosevelt delivered one of his most
important in the final days of 1944.
World War II was raging in Europe the
U.S hadn't entered the war but FDR was
still determined to help he explained to
the American people that they had a job
to do
we must be the great arsenal of
democracy for us this is an emergency as
serious as War itself we must apply
ourselves to our tasks with the same
resolution the same sense of urgency The
Same Spirit of patriotism and sacrifice
as we would show were we at War to help
the war effort and maintain National
Security at home the United States would
use its unmatched industrial
manufacturing capacity to help its
allies fight off the Nazis the Japanese
attacked Pearl Harbor less than a year
after he gave this speech and despite
wanting to stay out of the war the U.S
was dragged in but the arsenal of
democracy remains a powerful concept we
would all prefer to live in a peaceful
world that doesn't require armies
instead we live in a dangerous world and
in a dangerous world the best way to
stay safe is by becoming so strong that
no one will ever threaten you that
concept is called deterrence deterrence
that's what it's about is you scare
somebody away
doing something you don't want them to
do by making them fear the consequences
to do that they must know what the
consequences are
let's go from the middle of one war to
the aftermath of another after both
Nations played a leading role in
defeating the Nazis the U.S and Soviet
Union locked horns in the Cold War this
epic battle of ideology and Technology
spanned 45 years but the pressure of
keeping up with the U.S eventually
proved too much for the Soviet Union it
collapsed in December of 1991 under the
weight of a stagnant economy
unsustainable military spending and
civil unrest for most people the end of
the Cold War was great news but it was
bad news for America's defense companies
a world with an unchallenged superpower
was not a world with big demand for
American Military Hardware people even
started talking about a peace dividend
basically taking money which used to be
spent on National Security and putting
it into health education or tax cuts
sounds pretty good in theory even Dick
Cheney who would go on to become George
W Bush's vice president talked about
cutting costs because we now face
neither a global threat nor a hostile
non-democratic power dominating a region
critical to our interest we have the
opportunity to meet our requirements at
lower levels and at lower cost
between 1991 and 1996 defense spending
fell by more than 15 percent an in-house
Pentagon study came to the conclusion
that the United States didn't need so
many companies making Fighters bombers
tanks submarines and missiles that was
the context which led to the Secretary
of Defense Les Aspen and his Deputy
William Perry inviting defense industry
Executives to the Pentagon on that
fateful night in 1993. one industry
leader called it the Last Supper the
administration officials wanted the
industry to become leaner and more cost
efficient again sounds great in theory
they encouraged the executives to
consider mergers he even said later that
we expect defense companies to go out of
business we will stand by and watch and
that's exactly what happened dozens of
prime contractors merged or were
absorbed into Mega corporations
venerable names like Hughes electronics
and McDonnell Douglas ceased to exist
firms like General Electric and Chrysler
sold their defense subsidiaries at one
point the industry was shedding one
thousand jobs a day it was great news
for the executives and shareholders that
the companies that survived their market
share went up and so did their market
capitalization but the defense sector
didn't become leaner it became less
competitive and the remaining defense
crimes learned how to charge More For
Less the US government was happy to take
some of its battleships off the board
but back then in the Carefree and
optimistic 1990s it didn't seem like a
problem after all it was the 90s nothing
was a problem former Eastern Bloc states
were slowly but surely traveling the
long road to democracy Bill Clinton was
the first baby boomer president money
was easy and so was life the U.S felt
Invincible 911 the great financial
crisis the war on terror these were all
specs on the horizon in the words of the
political scientist Francis fukuyama it
felt like living in the end of history
but history hadn't ended it was just
taking a deep breath and around the same
time that the United States was taking
its battleships off the board on the
other side of the Pacific Ocean China
was building hundreds of them
throughout the 1990s China experienced
the biggest economic boom in history
hundreds of millions of people were
lifted out of poverty and the country
went from being a relative economic
Backwater to a manufacturing Powerhouse
and full-fledged member of the
International Community
the prosperity created by the boom gave
the Chinese Communist party's leaders
the means to reclaim what they saw is
China's rightful place in the world
order no leader has gone about that task
with more Vigor than season pair we
should strengthen National Defense and
army modernization building the People's
Army into a great wall of Steel under
his one-man rule China has adopted an
increasingly aggressive foreign policy
he wants to cement his own authority and
enhance the legitimacy of the Communist
Party the best way to do that is by
shaping the International System so it
more closely aligns with China's
geopolitical interests and the best way
to do that is by modernizing China's
Armed Forces to the point where they can
respond to any perceived provocation
coerce their adversaries into doing what
China wants and take on the United
States in the asia-pacific region so how
exactly has Xi Jinping expanded the
military capabilities of the people's
Liberation Army or pla there's Luke
concern tonight about China's military
capabilities amid a report the country
recently tested a new nuclear-capable
Hypersonic missile and it's understood
that U.S intelligence had no idea that
China had moved this far ahead in late
2015 as part of a sweeping
reorganization of China's Armed Forces C
elevated the missile Force to the same
level as the Army Navy and Air Force in
a grand ceremony he even renamed the
second artillery Corps to the pla rocket
Force but it's not just theater China
has made huge strides in three different
missile classes the first is
anti-carrier ballistic missiles such as
the df-21d these are designed
specifically to destroy the aircraft
carriers and bases that have formed the
backbone of U.S military dominance in
Asia for decades U.S military planners
now have to Grapple with what was
previously an unthinkable scenario which
is that U.S aircraft carriers could be
completely obsolete in a conflict near
the Chinese Mainland the second is
land-based intermediate ballistic and
cruise missiles China has achieved a
near Monopoly in this type of missile it
did so by not signing up to the
intermediate range nuclear forces treaty
this agreement signed in the Cold War
aimed to reduce the threat of nuclear
conflict it banned the U.S and Russia
from deploying these missiles and
although the United States withdrew from
the treaty in August of 2019 China still
had a 30-year Monopoly on making them
China is also believed to have the
world's biggest stockpile of hypersonic
missiles because of the name people
focused the Hypersonic part on how fast
they go but actually the biggest issue
when it comes to defenses is that they
can fly very low because of the circular
nature of the earth if you have a radar
system you don't see it until close to
the last minute which makes it difficult
to intercept as of today the U.S doesn't
have Hypersonic missiles at all nor does
it have any reliable way of shooting
them down China's missile capabilities
pose huge threats to the U.S Navy and
the Pacific and U.S allies in the
asia-pacific region so does its Navy I
think it's important to understand list
shipbuilding capacity today if China was
to lose half of their Navy today it
would take them two to three years to
rebuild their surface Navy if we were to
lose half of our surface Navy it would
take us probably 20 years what's more
the U.S Navy predicts that between 2020
and 2040 the total number of Chinese
Navy ships will increase by 40 percent
today China is one of the few countries
that has successfully achieved the
nuclear Triad the ability to launch
nuclear missiles from the air land and
sea that gives Beijing something
powerful a reliable second strike
nuclear capability it can use to deter
and coerce its enemies Xi Jinping has
put hundreds of new battleships on the
board at the same time he's also seeking
control of new technology
one of the most worrying areas of
Chinese development has been cyber
warfare as much as we know the Chinese
have the biggest cyber forces in the
world China is investing hundreds of
billions of dollars in emerging dual use
Technologies so that the people's
Liberation Army can achieve Battlefield
dominance
specifically the pla is pursuing a
concept known as multi-domain Precision
Warfare fundamentally this is about
linking command and control
Communications intelligence surveillance
and reconnaissance to quickly coordinate
Firepower expose enemy vulnerabilities
and then exploit them at the heart of
multi-domain precision Warfare sit dual
use Technologies such as AI robotics
cyber infrastructure and automation when
it comes to modernizing its military
China's leaders have a key advantage
over the West there are simply no checks
on their power every institution in
China is subordinate to the Communist
Party The Party can steal whatever
technology it wants and then imprison
anyone who complains and no one can stop
them the Chinese started to prioritize
cyber warfare and information Warfare in
general very early in 1990s then
understood that the key of American
Advantage was the information advantage
and to win they needed to destroy the
this American Advantage China now leads
the world in 37 out of 44 key
Technologies covering a wide range of
critical Fields such as space robotics
AI biotech and Quantum Computing these
are of the technologies that will
determine the balance of power in the
21st century
now we don't know much about that
October 2020 war game but we do know
that the red team attacked clustered U.S
forces with hypersonic missiles while
also disrupting satellite Communications
in other words the red team waited for
the U.S commanders to do exactly what
they expected and then they destroyed
them
built a military that can take on and
defeat the United States but but that's
still only half the story to truly
understand how the US military lost its
Advantage we have to go back to the
middle of the 20th century and a time
when many of the West's most brilliant
scientists happily worked hand in hand
with their governments Kelly Johnson
built entire generations of new aircraft
at Lockheed Alan Turing devised
techniques that crack German ciphers
during World War II John Von Neumann was
an integral part of the Manhattan
Project and many of the Technologies
created in the furnace of War became
household Staples the internet personal
Computing GPS and commercial air travel
all are integral to the modern world and
they all began as military r d projects
incredibly in 1960 the U.S Department of
Defense accounted for 36 percent of all
r d spending and I don't mean in the U.S
I mean in the world but then something
began to change a lot of it can be
traced back to one man Robert McNamara
McNamara was a new kind of bureaucrat
before he became JFK's secretary defense
he was the first ever president of the
Ford Motor Company who wasn't a member
of the Ford family simply put McNamara
was brilliant as a dedicated disciple of
Scientific Management he was constantly
building models to find the most
efficient way of doing things he brought
that technocratic Spirit to the Pentagon
in the early 1960s McNamara instituted
the planning programming and budgeting
system McNamara was driven by a concern
that individual military departments had
to set their own budgets and his time at
Ford made him confident he could improve
efficiency and reduce waste in a
nutshell his reform meant funding would
be allocated based on strategic
objectives set by the dod's military and
civilian leadership it fundamentally
altered the incentives faced by Major
U.S defense contractors and it
inadvertently sowed the seeds of not
just the Last Supper but the problems
faced by the U.S defense industry today
let me explain McNamara believed that
the U.S already had the technological
advantage it needed to defeat the Soviet
Union all it needed to do to win was
allocate its resources efficiently when
it came to the Cold War McNamara was
right the U.S used its unmatched
industrial manufacturing base to build
the world's strongest conventional
military but technocrats like McNamara
are much better at seeing the world as
it is instead of seeing how it could be
different in the future thanks partly to
reforms he implemented the U.S defense
industry became obsessed with efficiency
and adhering to process became more
important than achieving real
technological progress in his
best-selling Memoir about Lockheed Skunk
Works division Ben Rich wrote in my 40
years at Lockheed I worked on 27
different airplanes today's Young
engineer will be lucky to build even one
he was right in the 1950s the U.S built
five generations of fighter jets three
generations of bombers and two entirely
different classes of aircraft carriers
and that's just in 10 years just the
1950s but the United States hasn't
fielded a new bomber plane since the end
of the Cold War not only are new systems
rarely being built the costs of building
them in the first place have skyrocketed
in 1969 an analyst in the office of the
secretary of defense gave some
interesting testimony about 90 percent
of major weapon systems bought by the
dod wound up costing at least twice as
much as the original estimate the F-35 a
fighter plane which was meant to be a
one-size-fits-all solution for the Air
Force Navy and Marine Corps is now
expected to cost taxpayers 1.6 trillion
over its lifetime in fact the cost of
developing fighter planes increased by a
hundred X from the 1950s to the 1990s
Ben Rich's Memoir was published in 1994
the year after the Last Supper the
problems he described have only become
worse since then
last year the dod released a report
about the state of competition in the
defense industry you wouldn't expect a
government document to read like a
thriller but this one does the report
found that the U.S military is
increasingly dependent on a small number
of contractors for Critical Defense
capabilities ninety percent of America's
missiles come from just three providers
every nuclear-powered aircraft carrier
is designed and built by one company
when Les Aspen and Bill Perry invited
the leaders of U.S defense companies to
the Pentagon for the Last Supper there
were more than 50 defense primes today
there are just five Lockheed Martin
Raytheon General Dynamics Boeing and
Northrop Grumman and they have learned
to operate in ways that wouldn't be
tolerated in other Industries
under the current system of procurement
created by Robert McNamara the U.S
government spends years defining
requirements before ever putting out a
request for a new system that approach
is increasingly out of step with a world
where our Rivals are aggressively
investing in new technologies in order
to catch up in 2018 the U.S under
secretary for research and Engineering a
man named Mike Griffin said that on
average it takes the United States 16
years to deliver an idea to full
operational capability compared to just
seven years in China that kind of
Advantage compounds incredibly quickly
even if your adversary starts with a
fraction of your power if they grow at
twice the speed you do soon they will
overtake and overpower you meeting the
threats of today requires developing the
Technologies of tomorrow if we can
return to what used to be this country's
Ace in the Hole our ability to try out
new ideas that is the best of this
country we have let our legal and
Contracting processes get in our way
under investment is also a huge problem
when people get out of line we've been
able to redirect that through a
combination of military force economic
sanctions and diplomatic right it's
always going to be those three things
the US falling behind on Military the
U.S having an equal on this will change
the game substantially today the
industry spends an average of just one
to four percent of its revenues on
internal r d by way of comparison
alphabet reinvested 15 percent of its
revenues into r d in 2020. there's more
AI in a John Deere tractor than there is
in any system that the U.S DOD is
Fielding until 2019 the United States
nuclear Arsenal was still operating off
of floppy disks okay now that we have a
handle on the problems what's the
solution
in China absolute power has been
concentrated in the hands of one man Xi
Jinping but not only does that run
counter to American values what's
happened to the United States defense
industry over the last few decades
should serve as a warning against
concentrating power instead to reboot
the arsenal of democracy we should look
to the lessons of the 1950s and 1960s we
should harness the talents of the
nation's best scientists and engineers
in other words we need to look to
Silicon Valley
[Music]
Decades of unquestioned U.S military
superiority were underpinned by a
network of Defense contractors that
designed and manufactured best-in-class
military hardware but that model is
about to become obsolete because
everything about war the way it's fought
initiated and even prevented from
happening is changing to see glimpses of
the future let's go to Ukraine
even before any of its soldiers marched
onto Ukrainian territory Russia launched
its Invasion with repeated DDOS attacks
and a trojan horse malware protocol
aimed at paralyzing Ukraine's command
and control structures both sides are
making extensive use of commercial
drones to spot enemy combatants and
improve the performance of their
artillery the war in Ukraine is the
perfect Showcase of what the next
generation of combat will look like
today's big defense companies may not
like it but software is finally eating
the battlefield the once clear lines
between different terrains and different
branches of the Armed Forces will become
increasingly blurry this is a future we
can't avoid China and Russian or
adversarial nations are not waiting and
have in many ways been much more
successful at adopting commercial
technology into their military process
Xi Jinping has publicly pledged to make
China the world leader in AI technology
by the end of the decade and Vladimir
Putin once said resources
[Music]
thankfully there are companies that
understand the scale of the challenge
ahead of us and they're building the
next generation of software-enabled
weapons
okay let's shift our Focus to Northern
Poland in late 2021. NATO forces knowing
that Russia's invasion of Ukraine is
imminent are running a military exercise
called project Artemis but they're not
just working with each other they're
also working with a Californian defense
startup named anderol anderol isn't a
typical defense company and Palmer lucky
the guy who started it isn't your
typical defense company founder he
thinks that to modernize the US military
you have to first modernize the U.S
defense industry think about any great
Tech entrepreneur people like Jeff Bezos
Steve Jobs Elon Musk Etc they all carry
distinct images of how the future could
look and they have a deep drive to build
the products that bring that future to
life that is really the reason that I
started thinking about what a Next
Generation defense company would look
like what would it look like to build a
company they could take those bright
people out of the advertising industry
out of the search engine optimization
industry out of the augmented reality
mustache and Emoji industry and put them
to work on things that were more
important but he also understands that
in order for that to happen the defense
industry will have to change traditional
defense contractors struggle with
software they struggle because they
can't compete with Silicon Valley for
engineering talent but they also
struggle because modern software
development practices run totally
counter to how they operate the USS
Gerald R Ford cost almost five billion
dollars to design and took eight years
and 13 billion dollars to build that's
hardware software on the other hand is
developed by shipping a minimum viable
product as quickly as possible seeing
where it fails and improving it to keep
up with today's threats the U.S defense
industry will have to move faster
luckily there's a model for how a
modernized defense industry could
operate every other industry in the
world most companies whether they make
software cars or Furniture invest their
own Capital into designing and building
their products and they don't get paid
until they sell a finished product out
there's actually a great example of a
company that quickly Engineers new
products and sells them off the shelf to
government Partners SpaceX and SpaceX
spends billions of dollars of private
capital on research and development and
according to NASA's own analysis it
designs Rockets three times cheaper than
NASA designing products this way can
also improve how the military spends its
money historically defense technology
precedes one long detailed project
proposal at a time these proposals are
driven by Good Intentions efficient use
of taxpayer money to meet military needs
but often many of the savings are
actually an illusion because although
this process does a great job of
answering the question of what the next
Battleship should look like it never
asks the question of whether a new
battleship is needed at all that's why
instead of competing with the defense
primes for the biggest contracts annual
starts by thinking about the problem the
military should be trying to solve and
then goes away and develops it without
being told to we're not saying Hey give
us a million this year a million the
next year a million the next year in
five years we'll have something we can
test we're saying you know what we're
just gonna spend 10 million dollars of
our own money we're going to prove to
you that this can be done in six months
not six years this helps it avoid one of
the biggest pitfalls of Defense
procurement while channeling the
Brilliance of the people who solve hard
problems for a living scaling up this
approach could drastically cut
development times Apple puts out a new
iPhone every year now I'm not saying
that the iPhone is as complex as an
aircraft carrier but I am saying that
the U.S defense industry could be doing
much more to study the world's biggest
consumer tech companies and learn some
valuable lessons about modern
development and Manufacturing techniques
encouraging the greater adoption of
commercial technology in the defense
industry is also an ideal way to
introduce something that's been sorely
missing for decades real competition the
wave of mergers and consolidations in
the wake of the Last Supper created an
industry where companies don't truly
compete with each other by lowering the
barriers to entry the U.S government
could tap into a huge source of new
ideas while actually restoring
competition and putting downward
pressure on costs after years of
willingly taking some of our biggest
battleships off the board anderol could
hold the secret to putting them back and
regaining the upper hand in a dangerous
world but there needs to be hundreds of
Andrews competing hard with each other
in service of a shared goal protecting
the Western world and everything it
stands for that's something we're
working through right now it comes back
to you how do they look at this so it's
not a cost but but it's a profit for
them
Navy's aircraft and
but the wars of Tomorrow Will Be won by
software and Hardware working in Perfect
Harmony that means the future will
belong to the Nations that Embrace
emerging Technologies and Empower their
scientists and Engineers to create the
next generation of weapon systems we're
living in the most unstable and
dangerous geopolitical environment since
the end of the Cold War the world is a
powder keg one spark could set it all
off the best way to credibly deter war
is through Superior technology but
instead of preparing for new threats the
US government took its pieces off the
board and told our defense industry it
was okay to stop innovating we no longer
have the luxury of time but by applying
lessons from Silicon Valley and
embracing the potential of Founders and
companies that break the mold the U.S
military can regain its Edge if you want
to learn more about the military origins
of Silicon Valley then just watch this
video next thanks a lot
[Music]